oh my goodness yes it's quite a mess
yes it is
look at all your art things doing up
here
oh
i wasn't using them anymore
i should probably just get rid of it all
have you looked in father's old desk i
honestly can't remember why we kept most
of this stuff to begin with
i mean why on earth did we save this old
broken thing don't you remember that
kite
we used to love flying that with mother
and father
well it won't fly anymore
out it goes
no looking back
[Music]
as i live and breathe
you need to be more careful when the
wind rises george you nearly lost your
kite and you two nearly lost your
georgie he might have got away
completely had i not been holding on to
the other end of that string
my goodness annabelle
have you done to your clothes you could
grow a garden in that much soil and john
yeah it's just as filthy
how do you know our names
because she's mary poppins cooks now i
say you look lovely as always
do you really think so
nice to see you jack good to see you too
mary poppins
[Music]
quickly what is it georgie has something
happened i was flying the couch when i
got caught on a nanny
whatever you talking about come come up
where did you get that kite
i found it in the park she kept it from
blowing away
mary
close your mouth please michael we are
still not a godfish
[Music]
gene banks still rather inclined to
giggle i see
good heavens
it really is you
you seem hardly to have aged at all
really how incredibly rude
one never discusses a woman's age
michael i would have hoped i taught you
better i'm sorry i didn't came back
i thought we'd never see you again
it is wonderful to see you
yes it is isn't it
[Music]
i suspect and i'm never incorrect that
you're far too old to give into
imagination
[Music]
no not yet
[Music]
some people like to splash and play can
you imagine that
and take a seaside holiday can you
imagine that too much glee leaves rings
around the brain
take that joy and send it down the drain
some people like to laugh at life and
giggle through the day
they think the world's a brand new shiny
toy
and if while dreaming in the clouds they
fall and go cause splat although they're
down and bent in half they brush right
off and start to lock and you wear
imagine that
[Music]
oh dear look the picture's changed as
though they've broken your carriage
wheel
that they have it's useless now useless
as a chocolate teapot the boat is
speaking and who do we think is going to
fix that ah there's the riddle then what
broke it fixes it that's what i say what
do you think mary poppins well i suppose
we have no choice but how are we going
to do that i know a bit about fixing
carriages but we can't fix the carriage
wheel it isn't possible
everything is possible
even the impossible
gather round everyone spit spot
georgie don't forget gilly
are we ready ready
[Music]
[Music]
bucks and mares cubs and does welcome to
our show of shows it is my great honor
to introduce this evening's renowned
guest the one
the only
mary poppins
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i haven't sung in years
i knew i couldn't possibly d flat major
you got it now let's get you all back
home
now if your life is
[Music]
simply be more incandescent for your
light comes with my lifetime guaranteed
[Music]
i received a call from rob marshall and
he left a very ceremonious quite charged
voicemail on my phone saying i had to
call him i was like oh god what is it
and he pitched me the idea of doing a
sequel to mary poppins and they wanted
to do it with me so i was blown away by
the whole idea of it
mary poppins was what opened my mind up
in the world up to movies and magic and
music
so doing a sequel to mary poppins you
know the first thing you think is gulp
but then you realize that there were
eight books altogether there was a real
sense that there's so much more story to
be told it's really exciting i mean the
chance to explore that world even more
in this new original story with
incredible enchanting original music
how'd you do that do what it was pretty
clear there was no one else that could
play this role as brilliantly as emily
blunt what brings you here after all
this time same thing that brought me the
first time i've come to look after the
bank's children
oh yes you too
it's so wonderful the soul of the movie
it's about the power of the imagination
there's a real sense
that we're part of something very
special
we all cared so deeply about the project
because this is a film with great hope
and spectacle
and it's moving
so i think it's a very important film to
be making right now
are we ready ready
mary poppins can turn the mundane into
something magical
how'd you do that do what
she is so enigmatic indeed and batty
free and funny you really think so all
of these things don't feel like so
[Music]
and was swept away by the kind of joy
she infused into these children's lives
take your places
are you sure this is quite safe not in
the slightest ready
there's a comforting feeling with mary
poppins that she just flies in and she
makes it right
[Music]
that
again
of magic and reassurance has been the
thing that's really who she is
[Music]
it's my great honor to introduce
evening's renowned guest
the one
the only
mary poppins
mary poppins returns really is the next
chapter
the first film is a classic one of
disney's most prized possessions
that character impacted people in such a
big way
and this film was not a remake of mary
poppins which i think is an impossible
thing
but a sequel
morning jack our film is set 25 years
after the first film the bank's children
are now grown up and michael banks has
three children of his own and times are
hard in london and michael is in danger
of losing his home
and in comes mary poppins
and i got caught on a nanny to take care
of the bank's family again what brings
you here after all this time same thing
that brought me the first time i've come
to look after the bank's children us oh
yes you too
emily blunt is the perfect mary poppins
there would be no film without her it is
a part she's born to play
she's got a great sense of comic timing
oh pish-posh she's just practically
perfect in every way it's wonderful to
see you
yes it is isn't it
that's wrong i mean the scale is it is
huge i've never done a film on this
scale before
the entire creative team have really
taken painstaking measures to evoke that
sense of childlike joy and wonder
that's the thing about this movie
there's so much color and exuberance
don't we all need to be reminded of
magic in life we all need that we all
need a mary poppins in our life this
experience will always hold a special
place in my life
because this is a film with great hope
and spectacle
and it's moving
so i think it's a very important film to
be making right now
[Music]
ready everyone are you sure this is
quite safe not in the slightest ready
i play a character named topsy who is an
eccentric who runs a fix-it shop who can
fix anything i can fix anything topsy
and mary poppins have a very colorful
relationship
which was really fun to play this is my
cousin's second chasm
i would love to work with her on
everything
topsy is a woman whose world is turned
upside down every second wednesday of
the month
[Music]
oh no
the disorientation of that it's just a
great metaphor for life
when the world turns upside down the
best thing is to turn right along with
it
massive it's just whoa incredible i get
goosebumps thinking about it
let's say
you're
lost
in a park shore we've been preparing
this number for over
a year you can give in to the dark or it
required everything of everyone you can
trip a little light fantastic
with me
trip a little light fantastic huge dance
number with like
50 dances lamplighters are this magic
presence bringing light into the
darkness we've created this amazing
musical number using their tools of the
tray lamppost bikes and pyro and ladders
the fountain it takes ordinary life and
turns it into something special mary
poppins is the key to that
my first day of rehearsal when i first
spun around the lamppost and went how am
i gonna do this i practiced for weeks
dancing singing
the best bmx riders in europe to do
tricks amongst dancing they do enough
hundred and ten percent every single
tape
you genuinely feel like you've walked
into another world we're having the time
of our lives doing that number
[Music]
it was great
oh
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mary poppins
it is wonderful to see you
yes it is isn't it
[Music]
it's been a difficult year for our
family
everything's fallen to pieces since your
mother
famous
[Music]
whenever i lose my way i just look up
mary
what brings you here after all this time
we've come to look after the bank's
children us oh yes you too
it's a good thing you come along when
you did mary
[Music]
with my poppins gary what are you all
talking about
everything is possible
even the impossible
[Music]
you came back they've come to look after
the bank's children us oh yes you too
but we don't need a nanny we have grown
up a good deal in the past year we'll
have to see what can be done about that
no not yet
some people like to splash and play you
imagine that
how did she do that one thing you should
know about mary poppins
she never explains anything perhaps
we've learned when day has done some
stuff and nonsense could be fun
[Music]
everything is possible
even the impossible
are you sure this is quite safe not in
the slightest ready
disney's mary poppins returns ready pg
[Music]
i honestly can't remember why we kept
most of this stuff to begin with don't
you remember that case we used to love
flying that with mother and father those
days have long behind me
[Music]
as i live and breathe
[Music]
i'm flying because then i got caught on
a nanny
[Music]
mary poppins who came back you seem
hardly to have aged at all
really one never discusses a woman's age
michael would have hoped i taught you
better
[Music]
what brings you here after all this time
same thing that brought me the first
time i've come to look after the bank's
children us oh yes you too
we're about to lose our home
everything's fallen to pieces since your
mother
famous mother
nothing's gone forever only
out of place
it's a good thing you come along when
you did mary poppins
how'd you do that do what
[Music]
so you've been off filling the
children's heads with stuff and nonsense
you forgot what it's like
to be a child
[Music]
everything is possible
even the impossible
[Music]
off we go
[Music]
[Music]
you